has another kicking back with an end
date we are very excited about the
lighting
you're good at low latitudes gray we did
a little stuff outside
Elizabeth on an ATR over here we were
able to manipulate things
we're feeling very good about are
delighted to talk about the WNBA which
is obviously the Women's National
Basketball Association
they announced this week that they are
going to be the first professional
sports organization in the United States
it's going to market directly to gay
people has been a good gay here as I got
an age-old I'm
every weaken others say we got an A in
order in this week
I was in terms of sports keys and Colin
the NBA
Michael Savage is drafted in the NFL 'em
but this thing is really interesting in
this in a weird way be is
because now yeah dollars now it's like
yeah we r
particularly marketing who you
%uh so pretty great yeah it's great
I what it's because no one watches the
WNBA
that you probably have is gonna get to
the yeah
which sucks but you know I don't watch
basketball period so
have the gender I just here I know I'm
very
you say they are the latest small hard
core bass but yeah and it's not as big
as the NBA
yeah know that yet really right up
yeah I mean it sucks but I i think is
because
this is my speculation probably gonna
Hill
it may be because they don't have much
to lose and maybe they're like a
here's a market that we can appeal to me
the whole track viewership
yeah so I definitely think there's some
truth to that
obviously there's a lot of lesbian
players in
the WNBA there's a lot openly lesbian
players and I'm sure
that even beyond that there's actually
way more still the don't publicly say
or whatever and their been stories that
billion he was trying to sort it
immediately
the amount of people that were coming
out because they didn't want it will be
seen as
again the leaders know there's something
about this that makes it a little more
palatable remains remember that we need
and
yes such a great when you think about
that we will talk about gay sex
especially republicans there now
referring to you lesbians are always
for into gay men yes some reason they
have leagues visceral reaction to it
a little they're usually in there were
bad and so on
play in and so and there's a double
standard when it comes to lesbians and
gay guys because
lesbians they owns beautiful sexy turns
me on
with gay men look for some reason they
get turned off by it so yeah there's
that elements to it yeah
and I I think about the reaction that
people had to my house and after he
shared really tender moment with his
boyfriend after he got drafted
by the Rams right and directed by Ram
right
like people up you know happened and
reaction to it you know
really you're following there's nothing
wrong with it well that's the funny
thing because you know we've come so far
obviously and it's all great but when
when there was the reaction to the kids
you know that the next step
the next step up normalizing everything
is that a kiss
is just a kiss you know see here yeah if
love is everything yeah
J i loveeee aanay to drop her as a
I am but yeah the next step if you want
but we're all these people though he's
able one is not talking about this
the whole night when I you videos other
everybody to be the only time he's
eleven
it's a meet the just saw it become what
it is
he's just been issued cell up and we're
almost there and believe me
no one I don't know there will be
anybody on her now we happier to not
talk about the Gator
then the way it has had it is
yes normalize yet gay rights equal
rights Mullen
it not an issue anymore and he were
coming pretty close to that
we are coming pretty close do you agree
do you love the NBA team love lesbians
wealth every I like lesbians and yes
yeah
ok
me